my whole life is one intense love affair
with water i was born in sri lanka a
tropical island in the middle of the
indian ocean and as long as i can
remember
i've been drawn to it
i knew i wanted to be a marine biologist
but it was hard to actually visualize
being
while most of our planet's coastlines
are in the developing world the vast
majority of marine biologists are not
and finding a mentor or a leader in the
field is impossible
fortunately my parents empowered me to
believe i could do whatever i set my
mind to
they said do what you love and you will
do it well
i love being a marine biologist from sri
lanka and i love sharing what i discover
with everyone around me
every coastline needs a hero
a local hero
[Music]
you